brussels the capital of belgium and home
to more than a million people
for many it's also the world's chocolate
capital
the place to grandson is lined with the
shops of nearly all the country's top
chocolatiers
among them pierre marcolini
he gives us a warm welcome at eight in
the morning
hello nice to meet you thank you very
much
pierre keeps a busy schedule this
afternoon he'll be off to paris for a tv
interview but first it's time for
breakfast chocolate of course
makolini says he eats up bars worth
every day
i always tell people
when you eat our chocolate at home
take out a piece
and put it down somewhere
then close the packet and put it as far
away as possible
then go ahead and eat your piece
and if you don't do this you'll eat the
entire packet
this is mainly milk chocolate with a bit
of caramel and butter it's absolutely
addictive
this is the second time we've met pierre
we take a look at the report from our
first encounter
pierre has always been something of an
enfonterible in the culinary community
by the time we met in 2007 his
experimental creations had already won
him many accolades such as world pastry
champion
today he's considered one of the world's
best chocolatiers
his creations are sold in dozens of
specialty boutiques from hong kong to
new york
we set out for a tour through the salon
district it's a true insider's guide all
of his favorite spots are in this
neighborhood
notre dame
is a lovely example of gothic
architecture dating back to the 15th
century
right next door is the petit sablan park
an oasis of calm in the midst of the
bustling city
the district is a paradise for shoppers
looking for a special keepsake
nearly every corner has an antique shop
gallery or specialty boutique
like ogrondraswan one of pierre's
favorites
there's an unmatched selection of
straight razors and shaving kits from
around the world a perfectionist himself
pierre appreciates the quality on
display here and the owner's expertise
next we pay a visit to the gallery run
by patrick
which sells traditional artifacts from
all over the world
just a few days ago pierre bought a 200
year old wooden spear a wonderful
example of the craftsmanship he values
so
on this highly
this is what sablong is all about
there are so many unique things here in
places like the shaving shop in this
gallery
there's an excellent selection
everywhere
with knowledgeable advice expertise
the atomium is a popular tourist
destination as is the european
parliament
but we keep going
pierre wants to show me more of his
neighborhood
this building is another favorite it's
named old england the aunt nouveau
building is more than a century old once
a department store today it houses the
city's musical instrument
museum this luxury car dealership has a
surprise in store an in-house bar and
bistro
called why it's the latest project by
michelin star chef bart depotter it's a
place to get a quick bite without
skimping on quality
i enjoy a good meal just as much as i
enjoy a new chocolate
it's two in the afternoon
when we're done with lunch pierre
mcelini will leave for his interview in
paris
it's all in a day's work for one of the
world's most sought-after chocolatiers
from brussels